The Joe Rogan experience.
It's tricky.
If you find a thing,
they'll like works and then people like you should really concentrate on that.
I can remember Jamie Masada gave a friend of mine,
uh,
advice once way back in the day.
He's like,
you should be generation x guy when you go on stage,
you should be,
I'm from generation x every time you'll know like my generation,
generation x think this and talk like that.
But he was giving them advice and I was like,
listen to me.
Don't listen to that as Jimmy massage ever given good advice.
I don't know.
As Tiffany Haddish,
she's still mad.
He manages it.
Right.
So he's doing something right.
He's manages,
sir.
Yeah.
Like recently I actually fired everybody.
Maybe she fired him too.
Yeah.
I don't know.
She's a wild woman.
She can do whatever the fuck she wants now.
You know?
But you know,
I'm so happy for her.
I knew her when the shit wasn't going well.
You know?
She's always been wild though.
She's so while person it seems like.
Yeah.
In a good way.
Like,
yeah.
Yeah.
She's one of the two people that I saw like onstage.
It was like,
oh,
you're going to be a star.
Yeah.
Like I didn't know anything about her,
but I was just like,
you just start wasn't when she was creeping into the microphone.
No,
no,
it was not that.
Not that I've ever seen her do that.
No.
Dude,
she can make the most ungodly sounds with her vagina.
Like for real?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
She takes the microphone.
She puts it on her pussy and goes like she knows how to do it.
She has,
apparently she has an ability to make a noise with a vagina on cue.
Thanks.
I'm sure glad I did go before her.
How?
But if I had to follow that,
I'd be furious in front of six people.
Yeah.
Can I get a new mic?
I followed her before.
I didn't even think about it.
I probably should have,
you know,
I figure like the genes or filter enough.
Yeah.
You hope so.
I hope you know.
Still it's not ideal.
Yeah.
You like that type of person,
like that wild personality that like a garlic has that has like,
what the fuck else could she have done other than stand up.
I don't know.
But there's a lot of those people out there that never find stand up.
Oh Shit.
Then life just becomes chaos.
Like the crazy person at the office.
Yeah.
You know,
it's just stuck there and then you know,
you get fired from enough of those jobs where you can't even get that office job
anymore because you know the word gets out.
Oh yeah,
don't hire Tiffany.
That crazy bitch.
She's never going to be there.
And when she is there,
she's gonna Queef into the fucking loud speaker.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This I wish,
I mean,
part of me says no,
I don't wish that there was like some sort of an organized program to get into
comedy because figuring it out,
I figured it out.
You figured it out.
All of us did.
But then part of me says,
man,
there's so many kids out there.
There's probably a 16 year old kid right now who sees the hypocrisy in all the
things that these adults are doing and he fucking hates class and he's sitting
there right now going nuts.
Or there's a girl who's feeling the same way about all our stupid friends and
her mom and all these fucking people that want her to be a certain way.
And she's like,
Jesus Christ,
I gotta get the fuck away from these people.
And she makes her friends laugh.
But nobody ever tells her,
hey listen to me,
you could do this.
You could talk shit about things.
Like you can be a really funny comedian.
Like you've got to figure out a way to do that.
Nobody does that.
Like you.
It's so the,
the number of people that have the,
but like how many people have you ever met in your life that had the potential
to be a comic but never did it?
Like we are around them.
Me Like,
damn,
this guy's funny.
Can I a comment?
Five or six,
you know,
there are people who are like as
funny as me in college who just went on and got jobs and I got funnier,
you know,
like that.
I knew people like that are people.
One of the funniest guys I've ever met in my life was like a,
was like an executive producers Pa,
but he was so goddamn funny.
I couldn't believe it,
but he like,
I don't think it would have translated to the stage.
There's something like,
there's something you have to figure out in yourself to become a good community
in.
If you're the funniest guy in the world.
Yes.
You know,
it's a different,
it's a different muscle.
Okay.